tonight they will face the right-hander
luis garcia big right-hander for dusty
baker numbers on the season in six games
four of those have been starts he has
yet to record a big league victory
tonight would be a great night to get
that number filled up with that one
era 3.28 that whip is beautiful right at
one and at home era 1.64
kind of hard to believe he hasn't won a
game yet because it feels like he keeps
his team in every game yeah the one
thing i kept looking at with what garcia
was doing because he does keep everybody
in the game and the era proves out of
the 3.28 but the fact of the matter is
he just hasn't been able to extend those
outings and get deep into ball games
a little tapper back to luis garcia on
the 01 pitch and he'll make the play to
julie guriel and that's how this game
starts a little tapping comeback for the
astro starting pitcher so one out of
nobody on for the designated hitter
shohei ohtani hitting 276 326 on base
percentage time for first in the majors
with 10 homers 26 rbis swing and a miss
doubled up on a plumber and struck out
ohtani gave him the same look but a
little bit different location
away from otani and he couldn't stay on
it that was beautifully done two out of
nobody on for center fielder mike trout
leads the american league with a 376
average and a 488 on base percentage
eight homers 18 rbis
sharply hit altuve in a backhand play
gets rid of it in a hurry trouts out
what a play by jose altuve
he's not the only one that can make a
play from deep shortstop as carlos
correa gives him a fist bump on the way
back to the dugout it's gonna be an
interesting night for joe madden and his
los angeles angels as you see reliever
junior garrett getting his first start
of the season
it's going to be a bullpen evening for
the angels not sure how long garrow will
go as you see the 495 era on the season
he's gotten as many as three and a third
innings this season in relief
and thrown as many as 45 pitches
so that's kind of the goal today if not
more yeah i think at least one time
through the lineup if he can get him
that far
altuve takes one upstairs a four pitch
walk missing up on that first batter
altuve a lead off base runner for the
astros
and that one's up
so eight out of nine pitches out of the
zone the astros have two walks to start
this game alex bregman the batter and
altuve at second brantley at first no
score with nobody out in the bottom of
the first
alex hits one to right field slicing
away from taylor ward that's down for a
hit it bounces into the crowd that'll be
a double scoring jose altuve astros lead
one to nothing could have been two rbis
perhaps by taking a fastball down and
going the other way and alex has
actually done this a little bit here in
this homestead it's taking some of these
pitches and going the other way
counts even two balls two strikes on
carlos correa here's the next pitch he
got him to chase a fastball struck him
out and that's how the inning will end
paris strikeouts for guerra they get a
run but it could have been a lot worse
in the inning they will leave runners at
second and third third wash on third
taylor ward on first luis garcia is
allowed a lead off base hit to walsh and
then a bunt single to rojas and fielders
choice putting ward on first
ball hit to straightaway center field
straw all the way back still going near
the wall and he puts it away right in
front of the wall
head a long way by phil gosselin but
retired for the final out of the inning
garcia get through the second one
nothing astros bottom of the second kyle
tucker stands in and the first pitch by
guerras rip down the right field line
that's a base hit and that's going to
bounce all the way to the wall tucker
around first will cruise into second
with a lead off double so kyle tucker
continues
the pace he was on yesterday
a couple of extra base hits including a
home run
in the win over the blue jays yesterday
afternoon and starts off today with a
bang so for tucker that's his fifth
double of the year and he's in scoring
position for miles straw 3-1 pitch up
the middle that's going to be into
center field for a hit tucker around
third he'll score miles draw an rbi
single it is two-nothing astros
92-mile per hour to seamer to straw and
he sent it right back up the middle joe
madden's making the move and the angels
will indeed be making a pitching change
so castro's at second with two out for
brantley who walked the astros are in
danger of letting the angels get off the
hook again here three two
and that's line down the left field line
it's slicing away from upton and that's
gonna get down for a base hit and hit
the out of town scoreboard scoring is
castro brantley in the second with an
rbi double and it is three to nothing
astros brantley with his league leading
12-2 bagger just when you thought there
was going to be minimal hope uncle mike
steps in that's what hitters do
trout will be a lead off-beat runner
here in the fourth jared walsh the
battery singled his last time up next
pitch this is lifted high in the air
into right center and that's going to
drop and hit the warning track mike
trout is going into third he is going to
be waived home the throw is going to be
late trout scores all the way from first
base on that double right there by jared
walsh angels get their first run in
tonight's game and now trail it three to
one if it was anybody other than trout
running with a good relay by correa they
would have had an out a big spot here
for luis garcia if he's gonna pick up
his first majorly win he started the
inning up three nothing it's now three
to one but second and third here comes
the o2
breaking ball got him strike three
as garcia
wiggles out of the fourth inning
stranding a pair two out on for shohei
otani he has struck out twice both times
on change-ups against garcia the kick
and the pitch swing get a miss got him
on the curve ball so shohei ohtani has
struck out three times today garcia has
whipped seven a one two three inning and
through four and a half astros three
angels one all right correa at second
tucker at first two outs three to one
astros bottom of the fifth that's a line
drive that's a base hit by miles straw
in the left field correa will score
tucker to third straw to second rbi
double mile straw has driven in two
tonight it's four to one rbi's hurt so
badly straw out ahead of the breaking
pitch and karen walsh will be the next
batter here in the sixth inning
next delivery that one is hit well down
the right field side it's tight to the
line and that ball is out of here
boy jared walsh having a big night for
the angel single double and now homer
and he has driven in both angel runs
that cuts the astro leads at 4-2 all
right now it's upton with one out of
nobody on luis garcia has not completed
six innings as a big leaguer oh jay up
get out of here get going
back to back
start to train
oh now we got something to talk about
here boys boy jay up going uptown funk
back to back
justin upton all of a sudden got
yourself a ball game four to three in
this ballpark you're always in the game
back-to-back home runs to end the night
he'll leave with his team leading 4-3
and the angels are
very much in this thing here in this
inning trying to take the lead with
runners at second and third we'll see
what happens when gosselin steps to the
plate
ground ball to shortstop in the hole
correa picks it up had trouble with it
roja scores and the angels have tied it
in the sixth it was deep in the hole and
even had he fielded the ball cleanly not
sure that he would have gotten anyone
out anywhere a couple more runners on
base and the next batter will be butera
the catcher he shortens up gets the bunt
down here comes the go-ahead run
perfect execution from butera and the
angels have their first lead of the
night butera got down a good bunt and
belak couldn't flip it on target with
the glove to castro
trying to keep this at a one-run game a
walk in a single couple of stolen bases
and back-to-back strikeouts for raley
swaying and a foul tip caught by castro
and that's as excited as we've seen
brooks raleigh coming off the mound he
was fired up strikes out three in a row
tying run is in scoring position with
two outs carlos correa with a big swing
last time against iglesias in anaheim
here's the next pitch and this one is
chopped on the third base side gosselin
will get the tag on curiel and that's
how the ball game ends what a fabulous
win for the angels as they beat the
astros